ما زال اسم نادي النصر السعودي ونجمه
الجديد اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو متصدر الاخبار والعناوين فمن بعد
ما تم الاعلان عن تعاقد العالمي مع نجم
كره القدم رونالدو والمنصات امتلات
بالاخبار والفرح والاحتفاء بالاعلام ان
كان من خلال الصور اللي انتشرت لاستقبال
النجم البرتغالي في شوارع الرياض الي
احتفلت بالنجم على طريقه الخاصه او من
خلال صور وفيديوهات الاستقبال لناشره
النادي للحظات الاولى لوصول كريستيانو
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومن بين الصور والفيديوهات في فيديو منتشر
بشكل كبير وعامل تفاعل جميل وهو لاصغر
مشجع نصراوي كان حامل علم نادي النصر وعم
بقلد حركه رونالدو الشهيره وهي القفز في
الهواء
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا طبعا انضمام نجم كره القدم
البرتغال اللي الى نادي النصر السعودي منه
خبر يمر مرور الكرام وصحيح انه عامل ضجه
كبيره على وسائل الاعلام والمنصات بس تضجي
الاكبر هي الحفل المقرر مساء اليوم
وتحديدا مع بعض اقل من ساعه من الان وهو
حفل تقديم العالمي لنجمه الجديد كريستيانو
رونالدو المصري واللي راح يقام في ملعب
مرسول البارد بالرياض ومن المتوقع ان
يحضرون الف متفرج حسب المعلومات المتداول
وقبل حفل التقديم راح يكون في مؤتمر صحفي
للنجم عليك كريستيانو رونالدو ولي رئيس
مجلس اداره نادي النصر السعودي
وراح يتم بعد انطلاق فعاليات حفله تقديم
للي راح يكون مرتديلاله رونالدو قميص نادي
النصر اللي راح يكون عنوان وهويه جديده
رونالدو حتى عام 2025 الاقبال على الحفل
فقط توقعات وتم تداول معلومات واخبار انه
اكثر من 130,000 مشجع عم يبحثوا عن تذاكر
لحضور حفله تقديم لكن تم الاعلان عن انه
راعي راعي التذاكر راح يعود ل منصه احسان
الوطنيه للعمل الخيري
عن هذا الحدث الابرز ينضم الينا من داخل
وامام ملعب مرسول بارك في الرياض مراسله
العربيه فهد الشهري وعبد المحسن الحربي
نبدا مع فهد اهلا بك فهد
انقل لنا الاجواء الحماسيه من عندك ضعنا
في الصوره
[موسيقى]
اهلا مساء الخير للجوال جدا حماسيه
استعداد كبير توافق كبير قبل نصف ساعه فقط
تم فتح البوابات للجماهير جميعا انواع
الادوات
الميوزك ايضا الذباب المتنقل للاضاءات
الممر الشرفي اللي كان يبدا فيه نادي ريال
مدريد اول من بدا بتقديم نجوم ولاساطير
بدايه من كاكا ثم كريستيانو رونالدو
راح يتواجد اليوم في ملعب مرسول اقبال
كبير
ضخم احتفالات يبدوا انها ستكون يعني همم
مزامنه وتكون لائقه في هذه الاحتفال
الكبير بقدوم الاسطوره كريستيانو رونالدو
الجماهير في الخارج تحتفل بشكل هستيري
تنتظر القدوم واحتلال مدرجها اللي اعتقد
انه الملعب راح يكون فوق طاقته للسعوديه
راح اعتقد انه راح يكون
اعلى حضور جماهيري في تاريخ ملعب جامعه
الملك سعود وملعب مرسول بارك سيساعد على
ذلك انه اليوم كان في تعليق دراسه لا
دراسه العوائل حضاره كبار بشكل كبير طبعا
يوم ما كان في دراسه في مدينه الرياض
مناسبه الامطار الغزيره اللي من الصباح
الباكر الاحتفالات كبيره جيجي جاهز هذاك
المنصه الحمراء اللي تشاهدين هناك المنصه
الحمراء
اللي راح تقدم الكابتن كريستيانو رونالدو
الجماهير تحتفل تستعد تستعد ساعه بالضبط
ان شاء الله راح يكون تقديم كريستيانو
رونالدو اول مره
تيشرت فريق النصر
الحربي ليضعنا في الاجواء خارج الملعب
[موسيقى]
والمتوقع حضور ضخم لهذا الحفل الضخم ضعف
الاجواء
نعم الاجواء خارج الملعب لا تقل الحماس عن
داخل الملعب حيث يتوافق المئات من مشجعي
والالاف مشجعي ان النصر ومحبي كريستيانو
رونالدو الى مرسول باركلي الدخول وحضور
هذه الاحتفاليه الكبيره التي تقام لاول
مره على مستوى السعوديه حتى على مستوى
الشرق
اسيا همم
احتفاليه كبيره لاحد اساطير كره القدم
الذي نادي النصر كريستيانو رونالدو في
الحقيقه الجمهور بدا بالتوافق قبل همم
ثلاث ساعات من الان قبل وقت مبكر جدا لي
يحصل على مقاعدهم همم البوابات افتتحت قبل
ما يقارب نصف ساعه الى الساعه ودخل اغلب
الجمهور الى الداخل اعتزال عمليه الدخول
وتوافذ الجمهور الى داخل الملعب مستمر حتى
هذه اللحظه طبعا فقرات الحفل ستبدا بعد
ساعه قبل قليل همم الشاشه همم بالخلف همم
ذهبت الى الموقع الشرفي والدخول الشرفي
لمرسول بارك ربما هذا يشير الى قرب وصول
حافله فريق نادي النصر الذي سيجري تدريبا
همم الجماهيريا في الملعب احتفالا
بكريستيانو رونالدو وربما حتى وصول همم
كريستيانو رونالدو الى الملعب حتى الان
نحن نراقب الاجواء حيث من متوقع كرستيانو
رونالدو في ربما الدقائق القليله القادم
على ان يبدا الحفل الساعه السابعه الحفل
يتضمن العديد من الفقرات منها لكريستيانو
رونالدو كاليماري رئيس نادي النصر
بالاضافه الى اغنيه خاصه لكريستيانو
رونالدو
وايضا سيقوم كريستيانو باهداء الجماهير
عدد من الكور ل- همم الجمهور الحاضر في
حفل هذا الليله لتقديم كريستيانو رونالدو
للجمهور للمره الاولى بزي النصر وكذلك في
ملعب النصر
هل من وسائل اعلام اجنبيه لتغطيه هذا
الحدث
اللي فهد السؤال
بالفعل هنالك تغطيه كبيره جدا
[موسيقى]
لوسائل الاعلام حتى الان المؤكد ان 30
قناه حول العالم تنقل همم هذه همم هذه
الاحتفاليه الخاصه بكريستيانو رونالدو
بتقديمه في ملعب مرسول مبارك
للانضمام الرسميه
ايضا من وسائل الاعلام الاجنبيهاتها
موجوده في داخل الملعب لتغطيه هذا الحدث
الكبير الكثير من الوكالات الدوليه تواجدت
ليس فقط اليوم ولكن حتى منذ ايام حيث
الاعلان الرسمي ايضا همم
القاره الاسيويه الاوروبيه والافريقيه وكل
القارات والكره الارضيه اليوم ستتجه
المباراه الى ملعب برشلونه لمشاهده
كريستيانو رونالدو للمره الاولى خارج
اوروبا
للحضور الى هذا ملعب الضخم كم يتسع اصلا
الملعب بيتسع ل 25,000 مشجع لكن اعتقد انه
حيكون في دخول لاكبر اليوم حيكون في دخول
اكبر من الدعوات كانوا اليوم انت عارفه
مباراه يعني مو مباراه عفوا حبل تقديم
وليس مباراه فاعتقد ان الملعب هيكون في
30,000 لاول مره في تاريخ هذه الملعب
اقبال كبير
لشراء التذكره
فوق ال 100,000 فوق 100,000 اسالك عن
المشاهير الذين حضروا
[موسيقى]
شكرا جزيلا اداره نادي النصر واداره مرسول
البار
حه
وجه وزاره النصر وزاره الملعب مرسول مبارك
الدعوات اللي عده مشاهير على مستوى كره
القدم طبعا اللعيبه القدامى من النصراويين
اعضاء من وزاره الرياضه وايضا العديد من
المشاهير في مجال الفني والمجال الرياضي
في السعوديه وفي الخليج راح يحضروا اليوم
هذا الحفل للجميع اللي راح يكون على يعني
على قدر انتظار الاسطوره كريستيانو
رونالدو
[موسيقى]
فاصل ونواصل الحلقه